whether you're young whether you're old
age literally just a number what's
important is making sure to move
and move well all i need to do is follow
me and believe in yourself
i was a college football player i had an
injury
i hurt my ankle really bad i had
depression
i needed to fix my body and my emotional
state if i was gonna physically heal
[Music]
i realized my work was going to be
working on myself seeing how i could
then impact other people
my personal fitness and wellness
philosophy is about the ocho system
it focuses on putting physical health
first and then seeing how that
applies to other areas of personal
wellness to produce best results
it's flexible and can meet you where you
are so you want to do
the bare minimum to be effective to
really expedite your goals let's just be
better consistently every day
in this master class you're going to be
an active participant in your wellness
practices
so i'm going to teach you about
nutrition and then also how to actually
create your workouts
let's go
so i know what you're thinking i try to
flex my bicep i don't see anything well
that doesn't mean you don't have muscles
okay
everybody has muscle i hope you get a
little bit more or uncover the muscle
that you already have as you get
stronger
you feel better a little bit of muscle
and a little bit of strength goes a long
way
as we age
when we talk about eating with intent
what i want you to realize is when we
eat it has a purpose
research shows if i chop up broccoli and
let it sit for about 90 minutes
it unlocks the compound in the broccoli
that can help control your blood sugar
and has anti-cancer properties
all right i would say good luck but you
don't need luck because you're already
here you just show up and put into work
let go of your concept of trying to be
perfect maybe normal weight you may be
overweight you may be underweight it
doesn't matter
you have a body you're alive thank you
so at the end of the day
you just need you i'm joe holder
and this is my master class
[Music]
you